The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or to view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: I really stated
everything about discrete
coding as clearly as I
could in the notes.
I stated it again as clearly
as I could in class.
as I could in making up
problems that would illustrate
the ideas.
If I talked about it again
it would just be totally
repetitive.
So, at this point, if you want
to understand things better,
you gotta come up with specific
questions and I will
be delighted to deal
with them.
So we want to go on--.
Oh, there's one other thing
I wanted to talk about.
We're not having a new problem
set out today.
I don't think most of you would
concentrate on it very well.
I'll tell you what the problems
are, which will be
due on October 14th.
I'll pass it out later.
It's problems 1 through 7, and
the end of lectures 8 to 10,
and one other one all the way
at the end, problem 26.
So, 1, 2, 3, 4, 5,
6, 7 and 26.
So you can get started on them
whenever you choose and I'll
pass out a traditional problem
set form next time.
Last time we started to talk
about the difference between
Reimann and Lebesgue
integration.
Most people tell me this is
further into mathematics then
I should go.
If you agree with them after
we spend a week or two on
this, please let me know and
I won't torture future
students with it.
My sense is that in the things
we're going to be dealing with
for most of the rest of the
term, knowing a little bit
extra about mathematics is going
to save you an awful lot
of time worrying about trivial
little things that you
shouldn't be worrying about.
In other words, the great
mathematicians of the 19th
century who developed --
yeah, the 19th century, but
partly the 20th century.
These mathematicians were really
engineers at heart.
The 20th century and the 21st
century, mathematics has very
much become very separated from
physics and applications.
But in the 19th century and
in the early 20th century,
mathematicians and physicists
were almost the same animals.
You could scratch one and you'd
find another one there.
They were very much interested
in dealing with real things.
They were like the very best of
mathematicians everywhere
and the very best of engineers
everywhere.
They really wanted to make life
simpler instead of making
life more complicated.
One way that many people
express it is that
mathematicians are lazy, and
because they're lazy, they
don't want to go through a lot
of work, and therefore, they
feel driven to simplify
things.
There's an awful lot
of truth in that.
What we're going to learn here
I think will, in fact,
simplify what you know about
Fourier series and Fourier
integrals a great deal.
Engineers typically don't worry
about those things.
An awful lot of engineers, and
unfortunately, even those who
write books often state theorems
and leave out the
last clause of the theorem, and
the last clause of most of
those theorems the only way to
make them true is to add the
clause or not, as the case may
be, at the end of it, which
makes what they state absolutely
meaningless,
because anything you can add
or not, as the case may be,
and it becomes true
at that point.
The whole question becomes well,
what are those cases
under which it's true.
That's what we're going to deal
with a little bit here.
We're going to say just enough
so you start to understand
these major things that cause
problems, and I hope you will
get to the point where you don't
have to worry about them
after that.
Well, the first thing, we
started talking about it last
time, we were talking about the
difference between Reimann
integration and Lebesgue
integration.
Reimann was a great
mathematician, but he came
before all of these
mathematicians who were
following Lebesgue, and who
started to deal with all of
the problems with this classical
integration, which
started to fall apart
throughout
most of the 19th century.
What Reimann said, well, split
up the axis into equal
intervals, then approximate
the function within each
interval, add up all of those
approximate values, and then
let this quantization over the
time axis become finer and
finer and finer.
If you're lucky, you will
come to a limit.
You can sort of see when you
get to a limit and when you
don't get to a limit.
If the function is smooth enough
and you break it up
finely enough, you're going to
get a very good approximation,
and if you break it up more
and more finely, the
approximation gets better
and better.
If the function is very wild, if
it jumps around wildly, and
we'll look at examples of that
later, then this doesn't work.
We'll see why, in fact, this
approach does work.
Lebesgue said, no, instead of
quantizing along this axis,
quantize on this axis.
So he said, OK, start with a
zero, quantize into epsilon, 2
epsilon, 3 epsilon and so forth,
and everybody when they
talk about epsilon
they're thinking
about something small.
They're also thinking about
making it smaller and smaller
and smaller and hoping that
something nice happens.
So then what he said is after
you quantize this axis, start
to look at how much of the
function lies in each one of
those little windows.
I've drawn that out here, mu 2
is the amount of the function
that lies between 2 epsilon
and 3 epsilon.
Now the function lies between
2 epsilon and 3 epsilon
starting at this point, which
I've labeled t1, going up to
this point, which I've labeled
t2, on over here.
It's not in this interval
until we get back to t3.
It stays in this interval
until t4.
Lebesgue said, OK, let's say
that the function is between 2
epsilon and 3 epsilon over a
region of size, t2 minus t1,
which is this size interval,
plus t4 minus t3, which is
this size interval.
Instead of saying size, he said
size gets too confusing
so I'll call it measure
instead.
That was the beginning of
measure theory, essentially.
Well, in fact other people
talked about
measure before Lebesgue.
There are a lot of famous
mathematicians who were all
involved in doing this.
Anyway, that's the basic
idea of what measure
is concerned with.
Now, for this curve here, it's
a nice smooth curve, and you
can almost see intuitively that
you're going to get the
same thing looking at it this
way or looking at it this way.
In fact, you do.
Anyway, what he finally wound
up with is after saying what
the measure was on each one of
those little slices, how much
of the function lay in each
one of those intervals, he
would just add them all up.
He would add up how much of
the function was in each
slice, he would multiply how
much of the function was in a
slice by how high the
slice was up, and
then he'd get an answer.
One difference between what he
did and what Reimann did was
that he always got a lower bound
in doing it this way.
If he was dealing with a
non-negative function, his
approximation was always a
little less than what the
function was, because anything
that lay between 2 epsilon and
3 epsilon, he would approximate
it as 2 epsilon,
which is a little less than
numbers between 2
epsilon and 3 epsilon.
So this is a lower bound,
whereas this is whatever it
happens to be -- however you
decide to approximate the
function there, and there are
lots of ways of doing it.
Well, I won't prove any of these
things, I just want to
point them out so that when you
get frustrated with this,
you can always rely on this.
Which says that whenever the
Reimann integral exists, in
other words, whenever the
integral that you're used to
exists, mainly, whenever it has
meaning, Lebesgue integral
gives you the same value.
In other words, you haven't lost
anything by going from
Reimann integration to
Lebesgue integration.
You can only gain,
you can't lose.
The familiar rules for
calculating Reimann integrals
also apply for Lebesgue
integrals.
You remember what all those
rules are, you probably know
all of them better even than
this fundamental definition of
an integral, which is split up
the function into tiny little
increments, because throughout
all of the courses that you've
taken, learning about
integration, learning about
differentiation, learning about
all of these things,
what you've done for the most
part is to go through
exercises using these
various rules.
So, you know how to integrate
lots of traditional functions.
You memorized what the integral
of many of them is.
You had many ways of combining
them to find out what the
integral of many other
functions is.
If you program a computer to
calculate these integrals, a
computer can do it both ways.
It can either use all the rules
to find out what the
value of an integral is, or it
can chop things up finely and
find out that way.
As I said before, if you think
that being able to calculate
integrals is what engineering
is about, think again.
I told you before you
could be replaced
by a digital computer.
It's worse than that.
You could be replaced by
your handheld Palm,
whatever it's called.
You can be replaced
by anything.
After a while we're going to
wear little things embedded in
our body that will tell
us when we're sick
and things like this.
You can be replaced by
those things even.
So you really want to learn
more than just that.
For some very weird functions,
the Lebesgue integral exists,
but the Reimann integral
doesn't exist.
Why do we want to worry
about weird functions?
I want to tell you two
reasons for it --
I told you about it last time.
One thing is an awful lot of
communication theory is
concerned with going back and
forth between the time domain
and the frequency domain.
When you talk about things which
are straightforward in
the time domain, often they
become very, very weird in the
frequency domain
and vice versa.
I'm going to give you a
beautiful example of that
probably in the next class.
You can look at it --
it is in the appendix.
You'll see this absolutely weird
function which has a
perfectly well-defined
Fourier transform.
Therefore, the inverse Fourier
transform of this nice looking
thing is absolutely weird.
The other reason is even
more important.
We have to deal with
random processes.
We have to deal with noise
functions, which are
continuously varying
functions of time.
We have to deal with what
we transmit, which is
continuously varying
functions of time.
Just like when we were dealing
with sources, we said if we
want to compress a source it's
not enough to think about what
one source sequence is.
We have to think about
it probabalistically.
Namely, we have to model these
functions as sample values of
what we call a stochastic
process or a random process.
In other words, when we start
talking about that, these
functions which already look
complicated just become sample
points in this much bigger space
where we're dealing with
random processes.
Now, when you're dealing with
sample points of these random
processes, weirdness just crops
up as a necessary part
of all of this.
You can't define a random
process which consists of only
non-weird things.
If you do you get something that
doesn't work very well,
it doesn't do much for you.
People do that all the time, but
you run out of steam with
it very, very quickly.
So for both reasons we
have to be able to
deal with weird things.
The most ideal thing is to be
able to deal with weird things
and get rid of them without
even thinking about them.
What's the nice thing about
Lebesgue theory?
It let's you get rid of all
the weirdness without even
thinking about it.
But in order to understand it to
start with so we get rid of
all that weird stuff, we have
to understand just a little
bit about what it's about
to start with.
So that's where we're going.
Well, in this picture --
let me put the picture
back up again --
I sort of sluffed
over something.
For a nice, well-behaved
function, it's easy to find
out what the measure
of a function is.
Namely, what the measure is of
the set of values where you're
in some tiny little interval,
and that's straightforward, it
was just the sum of a
bunch of intervals.
But now we come to the clincher,
which is we want to
be able to deal with weird
functions too, and for weird
functions this measure, the set
of values of time in which
the function is in some tiny
little slice here, the measure
of that is going to become
rather complicated.
Therefore, we have to understand
how to find the
measure of some pretty
weird sets.
So, Lebesgue went on and said
OK, I'll define how to find
measure of things.
It's all very intuitive.
If you have any real
numbers, a and b --
if I have two real numbers I
might as well say one of them
was less than or equal to the
other one, so a is less than
or equal to b.
I want to include minus
infinity and
plus infinity here.
When we say the set of real
numbers, we don't include
minus infinity and
plus infinity.
When we talk about the extended
set of real numbers,
we doing include minus infinity
and plus infinity,
Here for the most part when
we're dealing with measure
theory, we really want to
include minus infinity and
plus infinity also because they
make things easier to
talk about.
So what Lebesgue said is for any
interval the set of points
which lie between a and b, and
he started out with the open
interval -- namely the set of
points not including a and not
including b, but including all
the real numbers in between --
the measure of that is what we
said before, and none of you
objected to it.
The measure of an interval ought
to be the size of the
interval, because after all,
all Lebesgue was doing was
taking size and putting another
name on it because we
all thought of it
as being size.
So the measure of the interval
ab is b minus a.
Now as engineers we all know
that it doesn't really make
any difference whether you
include a or you don't include
a when we're trying to find
the size of an interval.
So, he said OK, the size of that
interval is b minus a,
whether or not you include
either of the end points.
Then he went on to say something
else, the measure of
a countable union of disjoint
intervals is the sum of the
measure of each interval.
We already said when we were
trying to figure out what the
Lebesgue integral was, that if
you had several intervals, the
measure of the entire interval,
namely the measure
of the union of those intervals
ought to be the sum
of the measure of
each interval.
So all he's adding here is
let's go on and go to the
limit and talk about a countably
infinite number of
intervals and use the
same definition.
Now there's one nice thing about
that and what is it?
If we take the sum of a
countable set of things, each
of those things is
non-negative.
So what happens when we take
the sum of a bunch of
non-negative numbers?
There are only two possibilities
when you take
the sum of even a countable set
of non-negative numbers
and what are they?
AUDIENCE: Either to the limit
or it goes to infinity?
PROFESSOR: It goes to a limit
or it goes to infinity, yes.
Lebesgue said well, let's say if
it goes to infinity that's
a limit also.
So, in other words, there are
only two possibilities -- the
sum is finite, you
can find the sum,
and the sum if infinite.
Nothing else can happen.
So that's nice.
Then Lebesgue said
one other thing.
A bunch of mathematicians trying
to deal with this did
different things when they were
trying to deal with very
small sets.
Some of them said well these
very small sets aren't
measurable, others, and part of
Lebesgue's genius was that
he said if you can take a set of
points and you can put them
inside another set of points,
which doesn't amount to
anything, then this smaller set
of points should have a
measure which is less
than or equal to the
bigger set of points.
So that that says that any
subset of something that has
zero measure also ought
to have zero measure.
Now when we look at some
examples you'll see that
that's not quite as obvious
as it seems.
But anyway, he said that.
An even nicer way to put that
is when you're talking about
weird intervals, try to
cover that weird set
with a bunch of intervals.
If you can cover it with
a bunch of intervals in
different ways and the measure
of the bunch of intervals, the
countable set of intervals, is
you can make it arbitrarily
small, then we also say that
this set has measure zero.
So any time you have a set s
and you can cover it with
intervals which have arbitrarily
small measure,
namely we can make the measure
of those intervals as small as
we want to make them, we say
bingo, s has zero measure.
Now that's going to be very
nice, because it let's us get
rid of an awful lot of things.
Because any time we have some
set which has zero measure in
this sense, when we look back
at what we did with the
Lebesgue integral, it says
good, forget about it.
If it has zero measure
it doesn't come into
the integral at all.
That's exactly the
thing we want.
We'd like to get rid
of all that stuff.
So if we're going to get rid of
it we have these sets which
have measure zero, they don't
amount to anything, and we're
not going to worry about them.
Let's do an example.
It's a famous example.
What about the set of rationals
which lie between
zero and 1?
Well, rational numbers are
numbers where there's an
integer numerator and an integer
denominator, and
people have shown that there
are numbers which are
approximated by rational
numbers but they're not
rational numbers.
You can take that set of
rational numbers and you can
order them.
The way I've ordered them here,
you can't order them in
terms of how big they are.
You can't start with the
smallest rational number which
is greater than zero because
there isn't any such thing.
Whatever rational number you
find which is greater than
zero, I can take a half of it,
that's a rational number, and
that also is greater
than zero and it's
smaller than your number.
If you don't like me getting
the better of you, you can
then take half of that and come
up with a smaller number
than I could find, and we can
go back and forth on this as
long as we want.
So the way we have to order
these is a little
more subtle than that.
Here we're going to order them
in terms of first the size of
the denominator and next, the
size of the numerator.
So there's only one fraction
in this interval --
oh, I screwed that up.
I really wanted to look at the
set of rational in the open
interval between zero and 1,
because I don't want zero in
it, and I don't want 1 in it,
but that's a triviality.
You can put zero and
1 in or not.
So, anyway, we'll leave
zero and 1 out.
So I start out with 1/2 --
that's the only rational number
strictly between zero
and 1 with a denominator of 2.
Then look at the numbers which
have a denominator of 3, so I
have 1/3 and 2/3.
I look then at the rational
numbers which have a
denominator of 4.
I have 1/4, I have to leave out
2/4, because that's the
same as 1/2 which I've already
counted, so I have 3/4, Then I
go on to 1/5, 2/5, 3/5,
4/5 and so forth.
In doing this I have actually
counted what the integers are.
Namely, whenever you can take
a set and put it into
correspondence with the
integers, you're showing that
it's countable.
I've even labeled what
the counting is.
A sub 1 is 1/2, A sub 2
is 1/3 and so forth.
Now, I want to stick this set
inside of a set of intervals,
and that's pretty easy.
I stick A sub i inside of the
closed interval, which is A
sub i on one side and A sub
i on the other side.
So I'm sticking it inside
of an interval
which has zero measure.
Then what I'm going to do is
I'm going to add up all of
those things.
Whenever you add up an infinite
number of things, you
really have to add up a finite
number of them and then look
at what happens when you
go to the limit.
So I add up all of these zeroes,
and when I add up n of
them I get zero.
I continue to add zeroes, I
continue to have zero, and the
limit is zero.
Now here's where the
mathematicians have pulled a
very clever swindle on you,
because what they're saying is
that infinity times
zero is zero.
But they're saying it in
a very precise way.
But anyway, since we said it
in a very precise way,
infinity times zero here is
zero, the way we've said it.
But somehow that's not
very satisfying.
I mean it really looks
like we've cheated.
So let's go on and do this
in a different way.
What we're going to do now is
for each of these rational
numbers, we're going to put a
little hat around them, a
little rectangular
hat around them.
Namely a little interval which
includes A sub i, and which
also goes delta over 2 that way,
delta over 2 this way,
and also multiplies that by --
my computer knew I was going
to talk about computers
replacing people, so it
made some mistakes to
get even with me.
So this is delta times 2 to the
minus i minus 1, and delta
times 2 to the minus
i minus 1.
In other words, you take 1/2
and you put a pretty big
interval around it.
You take 1/3, you put a smaller
2/3 you put a smaller interval
around that and so forth.
Well, these intervals here
are going to overlap.
But anyway, the union of two
overlapping open intervals is
an open interval which
has a smaller measure
than with two of them.
In other words, if you take
this, the measure of this and
add it to the measure of this,
the union of this and
this is just this.
We don't have to be very
sophisticated to see that this
length is less than this length
plus length, because
I've double counted
things here.
So anyway, when I do this I add
up the measure of all of
these things and I get delta,
and I then let delta get as
small as I want to.
Again, I find that the measure
of the rationals is zero.
Now if you don't like this you
should be very happy with
yourselves, because I've
struggled with this for years
and it's not intuitive, because
with these intervals
I'm putting in here, no matter
how small I make that
interval, there's an infinite
number of rational numbers
which are in that interval.
In other words, the thing
we're trying to do is to
separate the interval 0,1 into
some union of intervals which
don't amount to anything but
which include all of the
rational numbers.
Somehow this argument is a
little bit bogus because no
matter what number I look at
between zero and 1, there are
rational numbers arbitrarily
close to it.
In other words, what's going on
here is strictly a matter
of which order we take limits
in, and that's what makes the
argument subtle.
But anyway, that is
a perfectly sound
mathematical argument.
You can't get around it.
It's why people objected to what
Lebesgue was doing for a
long time, because it wasn't
intuitive to them either.
It was intuitive to Lebesgue,
and finally it's become
intuitive to everyone, but
not really intuitive.
It's just that mathematicians
have heard it so many times
that they believe it.
I mean one of the problems with
any society is that if
you tell people things
often enough they
start to believe them.
Unfortunately, that's true
in mathematics, too.
Fortunately in mathematics we
have proofs of things, so that
when somebody is telling you
something again and again
which is false, there are always
people who will look at
it and say no, that's
not true.
Whereas in other cases,
not necessarily.
There are also uncountable
sets with measure zero.
For those of you who are already
sort of overwhelmed by
this, why don't you go to sleep
for three minutes, it'll
only take three minutes to
talk about this, but
it's kind of cute.
In the set I want to talk
about something closely
related to what people call
the Cantor set, but it's a
little bit simpler than that.
So what I'd like to
do, and this is
already familiar to you.
I can take numbers between zero
and 1 and I can represent
them in a binary expansion.
I can also represent them
in a ternary expansion.
I can also represent them in a
decimal expansion, which is
what you've been doing since
you were three years old or
five years older or whenever
you started doing this.
Well, ternary is simpler than
decimal, so you could have
done this a year before you
started to deal with decimal
expansions.
So I want to look at all of
the ternary expansions.
Each real number corresponds to
a ternary expansion, which
is an infinite sequence of
numbers each of which are
zero, 1 or 2.
Now, what I'm going to do is I'm
going to remove all of the
sequences which contain any
1's in them at all.
Now it's not immediately clear
what that's going to do, but
think of it this way.
If I first look at the
sequences, I'm going to remove
all the sequences which
start with 1.
So the sequences which start
with 1 and have anything else
after them, that's really the
interval that starts at 1/3
and ends at 2/3, because that's
really what starting
with 1 means.
This is what we talked about
when we talked about
approximating binary numbers
also, if you remember, is the
way we proved the Kraft
inequality.
It was the same idea.
The sequences which have a 1 in
the second position, when
we remove them we're removing
the interval from 1/9 to 2/9.
We're also removing the interval
from 7/9 to 8/9.
We're also removing the 4/9 to
5/9 interval, but we removed
that before.
So we wind up with something
which is now -- we've taken
out this, we've now taken
out this, and
we've taken out this.
So the only thing left
is this and this and
this and this, right?
And we've removed
everything else.
We keep on doing this.
Well, each time we remove one
of these, all of the numbers
that's -- when I do this n
times, the first time I go
through this process, I removed
1/3 of the numbers,
I'm left with 2/3
of the interval.
When I remove everything that
has a 1 in the second
position, I'm down
with 2/3 squared.
When I remove everything which
has a 1 in the third position,
I'm down to 2/3 cubed.
When I keep on doing this
forever, what happens
to 2/3 to the n?
Well, 2/3 to the
n goes to zero.
In other words, I have removed
an interval, I have removed a
set, the measure 1, and
therefore I'm left with a set
of measure zero.
You can see this happening.
I mean you only have diddly left
here and I keep cutting
away at it.
So less and less gets left.
But what we now have is all
sequences, all infinite
sequences of zeroes and 2's.
So I'm left with all binary
sequences except instead of
binary sequences with zeros
and 1's, I now have binary
sequences with zeros and 2's.
How many binary sequences are
there when I continue forever?
Well, you know they're an
uncountable number, because if
I take all the numbers between
zero and 1, I represent them
in binary zeroes and
1's, I have an
uncountable number of them.
Well, because I have to have an
uncountable number because
we already showed that any
countable set doesn't amount
to anything.
Countable sets are diddly.
Countable sets all
just go away.
So, anything which gets left
has to be uncountable.
Again, people had to worry about
this for a long time.
But anyway, this gives you an
uncountable set which has
measure zero.
So, back to measurable
functions.
I'm going to get off of
mathematics relatively soon,
but we need at least this
much to figure out
what's going on here.
We say that a function
is measurable.
Before we were only talking
about sets of numbers being
measurable.
We had to talk about sets of
numbers being measurable
because we were interested in
the question of what's the set
of times for which a function
lies between 2 epsilon and 3
epsilon, for example.
What we said is we can say a
great deal about that because
we can not only add up a bunch
of intervals, we can also add
up a countable bunch of
intervals, and we can also get
rid of anything which
is negligible.
So, a function is measurable if
the set of t, such that u
of t lies between these
two points is
measurable for each interval.
In other words, if no matter how
I split up this interval,
if no matter what slice I look
at, the set of times over
which the function lies in
there is measurable.
That's what a measurable
function is.
Everybody understand
what I just said?
Let me try to say
it once more.
A function is measurable if for
every two values, say 3
epsilon and 2 epsilon, if the
set of values t for which the
function lies between 2 epsilon
and 3 epsilon, if that
set is measurable.
In other words, that's the set
we were talking about before
which went from here to
here, and which went
from here to there.
In this case for this very
simple function, that's just
the sum of two intervals.
If I make the function wiggle
a great deal more, it's the
sum of a lot more intervals.
So, we say the function is
measurable if all of the sets
are measurable.
Now, what I'm going to do is
when I'm trying to define this
integral, I'm going
to have to go to
smaller and smaller intervals.
Let's start out with epsilon,
2 epsilon, 3
epsilon and so forth.
Let's look at a non-negative
function--.
Yeah?
AUDIENCE: Maybe I missed
something, but could you tell
me [UNINTELLIGIBLE] definition
for a set, if measurable.
PROFESSOR: What's the definition
for a set is
measurable.
I didn't really say,
and that's good.
I gave you a bunch of conditions
under which a set
is measurable, and if I have
enough conditions for which
it's measurable then I don't
have to worry about--.
I said that it is measurable
under all of these conditions.
I'm saying I don't have to worry
about the rest of them
because these are enough
conditions to talk about
everything I want
to talk about.
AUDIENCE: [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I will define
my measure as
all of these things.
Unfortunately, you need a little
bit more, and if you
want to get more you better
take a course in real
variables and measure theory.
Good.
So, if I want to now make this
epsilon smaller, what I'm
going to do is do it in
a particular way.
I'm going to start out
partitioning this into
intervals of size epsilon.
Then I'm going to partition
it into intervals of size
epsilon over 2.
When I partition it into
intervals of size epsilon over
2, I'm adding a bunch
of extra things.
This thing gets added because
when I'm looking at the
interval between epsilon and 3
epsilon over 2, the function
is in this interval here, over
this [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
It's in this interval over
this whole thing.
I'm representing it by
this value down here.
Now when I have this tinier
interval, I see that this
function is really in this
interval from here to there
also, and therefore, instead of
representing the function
over this interval by epsilon,
I'm representing it by 3
epsilon over 2.
In other words, as I add these
extra quantization levels, I
can never lose anything,
I only gain things.
So I gain all of these
cross-hatched regions when I
do this, which says that when
I add up all these things in
the integral, every time I
decrease epsilon by 2, the
integral that I've got,
the approximation to
the integral increases.
Now what happens when you take
a sum of a set of numbers
which are increasing?
Well, they're increasing, the
result that you get when you
add them all up is increasing
also, and therefore, as I go
from epsilon to epsilon over
2 to epsilon over 4 and so
forth, I keep climbing up.
Conclusion, I either get to a
finite number or I get to
infinity -- only two
possibilities.
Which says that if I'm looking
at non-negative functions, if
I'm only looking at real
functions which have
non-negative values, the
Lebesgue integral for a
measurable function always
exists, if I include infinite
limits as well as
finite limits.
Now, if you think back to what
you learned about integration,
and I hope you at least learned
enough about it that
you remember there are a lot of
very nasty conditions about
when integrals exist and
when they don't exist.
Here that's all gone away.
This is a beautifully
simple statement.
You take the integral of a
non-negative function, if it's
measurable, and there are
only two possibilities.
The integral of some
finite number or
the integral is infinite.
It's never undefined,
it's always defined.
I think that's neat.
A few people don't think
it's neat, too bad.
I guess when I was first
studying this, I didn't think
it was neat either because
it was too complicated.
So you have an excuse.
If you think about it for a
while and you understand it
and you don't think it's
neat, then I think
you have a real problem.
So now --
I did this.
I'm getting too many
slides out here.
Here we go.
Here's something new.
Hardly looks new.
Let's look at a function now,
just defined on the
interval zero to 1.
Suppose that h of t is equal to
1 for each rational number
and at zero for each
irrational number.
In other words, this is
a function which looks
absolutely wild.
It just goes up to here
and it's 1 or zero.
It's 1 at this dense set of
points, which we've already
said doesn't amount to anything,
and it's zero
everywhere else.
Now you put that into the
Reimann integral, and the
Reimann integral goes crazy,
because no matter how small I
make this interval, there are an
infinite number of rational
numbers in that interval, and
therefore, the Reimann
integral can never
even get started.
For the Lebesgue integral, on
the other hand, look at what
happens now.
We have a bunch of points which
are sitting at 1, we
have a bunch of points which
are sitting at zero.
The only thing we have to do is
evaluate the measure of the
set of points which are up in
some tiny interval up in here.
What's this measure of the set
of t's corresponding to the
rational numbers?
Well, you already said
that was zero.
Now, that's why Lebesgue
integration works.
Any countable set, and in fact,
any of these uncountable
sets that measure zero get lost
in here because you're
combining them all together
and you say they don't
contribute to the
integral at all.
That's why Lebesgue integration
is so simple.
You can forget about
all that stuff.
When we looked last time at
the Fourier series for a
square wave, you remember we
found that everything behaved
very nicely, except where
the square wave had a
discontinuity, the Fourier
series converged to the
mid-point, and that was
kind of awkward.
Well, the mid-points where the
function is discontinuous
don't amount to anything,
because in that case there
were just two of them, there
were only two points.
If they had measure zero
it just washes away.
You all felt intuitively when
you saw that example, that
those points were
not important.
You felt that this was
mathematical carping.
Well, Lebesgue felt it was
mathematical carping too, but
he went one step further and
he said here's a way of
getting rid of all of that
and not having to
worry about it anymore.
So you've now gotten to the
point where you don't have to
worry about any of this
stuff anymore.
Now let's go a little
bit further.
We're almost at the
end of this.
If I take a function which maps
the real numbers into the
real numbers, in other words,
it's a function which you can
draw on the line.
You take time going from minus
infinity to plus infinity, you
define what this function
is at each time.
That's what I'm talking
about here, a function
which you can draw.
The functions magnitude of
u of t, and the function
magnitude of u of t squared
are both non-negative.
Now I'm not going to prove this,
but it turns out that
the magnitude and the magnitude
squared are both
measurable functions if u of
t is a measurable function.
In fact, from now on we're
just going to assume that
everything we deal with is
measurable, every function is
measurable.
I challenge any of you without
looking it up in a book to
find an example of a
non-measurable function.
I challenge any of you to
find an example of a
non-measurable set.
I challenge any of you to
understand the definition of a
non-measurable set if you
look it up in a book.
You've heard about things like
the axiom of choice and things
like that, which are very
fishy kinds of things --
that's all involved in finding
non-measurable function.
So, any function that you think
about is going to be
measurable.
I hate people who say things
like that, but it's the only
way to get around this because
I don't want to give you any
examples of that because
they're awful.
Since magnitude of u of t and
magnitude of u of t squared
are measurable and they're
non-negative,
their integrals exist.
Their integrals exist and are
either a finite number or
they're infinite.
So, we define L1 functions, and
we'll be dealing with L1
functions and L2 functions all
the way through the course, u
of t is an L1 function if it's
measurable, and if this
integrals is less
than infinity.
That's all there is to it.
u2 is L2 if it's measurable
and the integral of u of t
squared is less than infinity.
I could have said that at the
beginning, but now you see
that it makes a lot more sense
than it did before because we
know that if u of t is
measurable, this integral
exists -- it's either a finite
number or infinity.
The L1 functions are those
particular functions where
it's finite and not infinite.
Same thing here.
The L2 functions are those
where this is finite.
This is really the energy of the
function, but now we can
measure the energy of even weird
functions which are zero
on the irrationals and
one on the rationals.
Even things which are zero on
the non-cantor set points and
1 on the cantor set points,
still it all works.
So those define the
set L1 and L2.
Now, a complex function u of
t, which maps r into c, why
does a complex function
map r into c?
What's the r doing there?
Think of any old complex
function you can think of.
e to the i, 2 pi t.
That's something that wiggles
around, the sinusoid.
t is a real number.
So that function e to the i 2
pi t is mapping real numbers
into complex numbers.
That's what we mean by something
which maps the real
numbers into complex numbers.
We always call these
complex functions.
I mean mathematicians
would say yeah, a
function could be anything.
But you know, when most of us
think of a function, we're
thinking of mapping a real
variable into something else,
and when we're thinking of
mapping a real variable into
something else, we're usually
thinking of mapping it into
real numbers or mapping it
into complex numbers, and
because we want to deal with
these complex sinusoids, we
have to include complex
numbers also.
So a complex function is
measurable by definition if
the real part and the imaginary
part are each
measurable.
We already know when a real
function is measurable.
Namely, a real function is
measurable if each of these
slices are measurable.
So now we know when a complex
function is measurable.
We already said that all of the
complex functions you can
think of and all the ones we'll
ever deal with are all
measurable.
So L1 and L2 are defined in
the same way when we're
dealing with complex
functions.
Namely, just whether this
integral is less than infinity
and this integral is
less than infinity.
Since these functions -- this
is a real function from real
into real, this is a real
function from real into real.
So those are well-defined.
What's the relationship
between L1
functions and L2 functions?
Can a function be
L1 and not L2?
Can it be L2 and not L1?
Yeah, it can be both,
unfortunately.
All possibilities exist.
You can have functions which
are neither L1 nor L2,
functions that are L1 but not
L2, functions that are L2 but
not L1, and functions that
are both L1 and L2.
Those are the truly nice
functions that we
like to deal with.
But there's one nice that you
can say, and that follows from
a simple argument here.
If u of t is less than or equal
to 1, if the magnitude
of u of t is less than
or equal to 1--.
Let's start out by looking at
u of t being greater than or
equal to 1.
If u of t is greater than or
equal to 1, then u squared of
t is even bigger.
You see the thing that happened
is when u of t
becomes bigger than
t, u squared of t
becomes even more bigger.
When u of t is less than
1, u squared of t is
less than u of t.
But if u of t is less than or
equal to 1, it's less than 1.
So in all cases, for all t, u
of t, magnitude is less than
or equal to u of t
squared plus 1.
So that takes into account
both cases.
It's a bound.
So if I'm looking at functions
which only exist between over
some limited time interval, and
I take the integral from
minus t over 2 to the t over 2
of the magnitude of u of t, I
get something which is less than
or equal to the integral
of u squared of t plus the
integral of 1, and the
integral of 1 over this finite
limit is just t.
This says that if a function
is L2 and the function only
exists over a finite interval,
then the function is L1 also.
So as long as I'm dealing with
Fourier series, as long as I'm
dealing with finite duration
functions, L2 means L1.
All of the nice things that
you get with L1 functions
apply to L2 functions also, and
there are a lot of nice
things that happen
for L1 functions.
There are a lot of nice things
that happen for L2 functions.
You take the union of what
happens for L1 and for L2, and
that's beautiful.
You can say anything then.
Can't calculate anything, of
course, but we all said, we
leave that to computers.
Let's go back Fourier
series now, let's go
back to the real world.
Any old function we have u of t,
the magnitude of u of t and
the magnitude of u of t times
either the 2 pi ift, for any
old f, this thing has magnitude
1, right, a complex
exponential.
Real f, real t.
This just has magnitude 1.
And therefore, this magnitude
is equal to this magnitude.
This says that if the function
u of t is L1, then the
function u of t times either the
2 pi IFT is also L1, which
says if we can integrate one
we can integrate the other.
In other words, the integral
of u of t, either the 2 pi
ift, the magnitude of
the fdt is going to
be less than infinity.
Since we're taking the
magnitude, it's either finite
or it's infinite, and since u
of t in magnitude when we
integrate it is less than
infinity, this thing is less
than infinity also.
Now, this is a complex
number in here.
So you can break it up into a
real part and an imaginary
part, and if this whole thing,
if the magnitude is less than
infinity, then the magnitude
of the real part is finite.
If you take the real part over
the region where this is
positive and the region where
it's negative, you still get
non-negative numbers.
In other words, if we're
taking the integral of
something which has
positive values --
I should have written this out
in more detail, it's not
enough to--.
I'm taking the integral
of something which--.
This is u of t.
If I can find another color.
Let me draw magnitude of
u of t on top of this.
This thing here is magnitude
of u of t.
What?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: I'm making it real
for the time being because I'm
just looking at the real part.
In other words, what I'm looking
is this quantity here.
Later you can imagine doing the
same thing out on complex
numbers, OK?
So what I'm saying is if I just
look at the real part of
u of t -- call this real part
of u of t, if you like.
If I know that this is finite,
this is non-negative, I know
that the positive part of this
function has a finite
integral, I know that the
negative part of it has a
finite integral.
In other words, the thing which
makes integration messy
is you sometimes have the
positive part being infinite,
the negative part being infinite
also, and the two of
them cancel out somehow to give
you something finite.
When you're dealing with the
magnitude of u of t, if the
magnitude of u of t has an
infinite integral, then that
messy thing can't happen.
It says that the positive part
has a finite integral, the
negative part has a finite
integral also.
If you take the imaginary part,
visualize that out this
way, the positive part of the
imaginary part has a finite
integral, the negative part of
the imaginary part has a
finite integral also.
It says if the magnitude of u
of t, that integral always
exists, and if it's finite, then
these positive parts of
the real, the positive part of
the imaginary part, all of
those are finite, and it says
the integral itself is finite.
Which says that this integral
here has to be finite.
Namely, the positive part of
the real part, the negative
part of the real part, the
positive part of the imaginary
part, the negative part of the
imaginary part, all four have
to be finite, just because this
quantity here is finite.
Now, if u of 2 is L2 and also
time limited, it's L1, and the
same conclusion follows.
So this integral always
exists if it's
over a finite interval.
So at this point we're really
ready to go back to this
theorem about Fourier series
that we stated last time and
which was a little bit
mysterious at that point.
In fact, at this point we've
already proven part of it.
I wanted to prove it because I
wanted you to know that not
everything in measure
theory is difficult.
An awful lot of these things,
after you know just a very
small number of the ideas,
are very, very simple.
Now, you will think this is not
simple because you haven't
had time to think about
the ten slides
that have gone before.
But if you go back and you look
at them again, if you
read the notes, you will see
that, in fact, it all is
pretty simple.
What this says is if u of t, a
complex function real into c,
but time limited, suppose it's
an L2 function, then it's also
L1 over that interval minus
t over 2 to plus t over 2.
Then for each k and z, then
for each integer k, this
integral here, this function
here, is now an L1 function,
and therefore, this integral
exists, is finite.
You divide by t is
still finite.
So that Fourier coefficient
has to exist and it has to
exist as a finite value.
Now, you look at Reimann
integration, and you look at
the theorems about Reimann
integration, and if they're
stated by somebody who was
stating theorems, the
conditions are monstrous.
This is not monstrous.
It says all you need is
measurability and L1, which
says it doesn't go
up to infinity.
That's enough to say that every
one of these Fourier
coefficients has to exist.
It might be hard to integrate
it, but you
know it has to exist.
Now the next thing it says
is that -- this is more
complicated.
What we would like to say and
what we tried to say before
and what you like to say with
the Fourier series is that u
of t is equal to this, where you
sum from minus infinity to
plus infinity.
We saw that we can't say that.
We saw that we can't it for
functions which have step
discontinuities, because
whenever you have a step
discontinuity, the Fourier
series converges to the
mid-point of that
discontinuity.
If you were unfortunate enough
to try to make life simple and
define the function without
defining it at the step
discontinuity as the mid-point,
then the Fourier
series would not be
equal to u of t.
But what this says is that if
you take the difference
between u of t and a finite
expansion, and then you look
at the energy in that
difference, it says that the
energy and the difference
goes to zero.
Now that's far more important
than having this integral be
equal to that, because frankly,
we don't care a fig
for whether this is equal to
this at every t or not.
What we care about is when we
add more and more terms onto
this Fourier series.
I mean in engineering we're
always approximating things.
We have to approximate things.
We talk about functions u of
t, but our functions u of t
are just models of things
anyway, and we want those
models to really converge to
something, which means that as
we take more and more terms in
the Fourier series, we get
something which comes closer to
u of t and it comes closer
in energy terms.
Remember when we take this, when
we approximate it in this
way by a finite Fourier series,
and we then quantize
coefficients, and then we go
back to the function, we have
lost all the coefficients and
all of these terms for the
very high frequencies.
We've dropped them off.
What this says is if we take
more and more of them and then
we quantize and we go back to
a function v of t it says as
we add more and more Fourier
coefficients and quantize
carefully, we can come closer
and closer to the function
that we started with.
You don't get that by talking
about point to point equality,
because as soon as we quantize
you lose all of that anyway.
You don't have a quality
anywhere anymore, and the only
thing you can hope for is a
small mean square error.
So, this looks more complicated
than what you
would like, but what I'm trying
to tell you is that
this is far more important
than what you would like.
What you would like is
not important at all.
I can give you examples of
things where this converges to
this everywhere, but in fact,
no matter how many terms you
take, the energy difference
between these two things is
very large.
Those are the ugly things.
That says you never get a good
approximation, even though
looking at things point-wise
everything looks great.
But what you're really
interested in is these mean
square approximations and what
this Fourier series thing says
is that if you deal with
measurable functions then this
converges just to that in this
very nice energy sense, and
energy is what we're
interested in.
The final part of this --
I mean I talked about this
a little bit last time --
sometimes instead of starting
out with a function and
approximating it with the
Fourier series, you want to
start out with the coefficients
and find the function.
In fact, when we start talking
about modulation, that's
exactly what we're going to be
doing because we're always
going to be starting out with
these digital sequences, we're
going to be finding functions
from the digital sequences.
This final part of the theorem
says yes, you can
do that and it works.
It says that given any set
of coefficients where the
coefficients have finite energy,
in other words, where
the sum is less than infinity,
then there's an L2 function, u
of t, which satisfies the above
in this limiting sense.
Now this is the hardest thing
of the theorem to prove.
It looks obvious but it's not.
But anyway, it's there.
It says these approximations are
rock solid and you can now
forget about all of this measure
theoretic stuff, and
you can just live with the
fact that all of these in
terms of L2 approximations,
work.
I mean again, it doesn't look
beautiful at this point
because you haven't seen
it for long enough.
It really is beautiful.
It's beautiful stuff.
When you think about it long
enough, for 40 years is how
long I've been thinking about
it, it becomes more and more
beautiful every year.
So, if you live long enough
it'll be beautiful.
Any time you talk about this
type of convergence, we call
it convergence in the mean, and
then notation we will use
is l.i.m., which looks like
limit but which really stands
for limit in the mean.
We will write that complicated
thing on the last slide, which
I said is not really that
complicated, but we will write
this as this.
In other words, when we write
limit in the mean, we mean
that the difference between
these two sides in energy
sense goes to zero
as k gets large.
That's what this limit means.
It just means the statement that
we talked about before.
So the Fourier series, the
theorem really says you can
find all of the Fourier
coefficients in this way, they
all exist, they all exist
exactly, they're all finite.
The function then exists as this
limit in the mean, which
is the thing that we're
always interested in.
So, every L2 function defined
over a finite interval, and
every L1 function defined over
a finite interval, all of
these have a Fourier series
which satisfies these two
relationships.
Now, what we're going to do
with all of this is we're
going to segment an arbitrary
function, an arbitrary L2
function over the entire time
range, and we're going to
segment it into pieces,
all of width t.
Then we're going to expand each
of those segments into a
Fourier series.
That's what people do any time
they compress voice that I
said several times.
When you compress voice --
for some reason or other
everybody does it in 20
millisecond increments.
You chop up the voice into 20
You then, at least, conceptually
look at those 20
millisecond increments, think
of them in terms of the
Fourier series, you expand them
in the Fourier series.
So for each increment in time
we get a different Fourier
series, and we use those Fourier
series to approximate
the function.
So, each one of the increments
now is going to be represented
in this way here.
Since we're only looking at
the function now over the
interval around time, mt, we
look at it this way, we
calculate the coefficients,
again, in terms of this
rectangular function
spaced off by m.
This is saying the same thing
that we said before, just
moving it from minus t over 2
to t over 2 to t minus mt.
Here's minus t over 2.
The t over 2.
Next we're looking at t
over 2 to 3t over 2.
Next we're looking
at 5t over 2.
This is m equals zero.
This is m equals 1.
This is m equals 2.
This notation here you should
get used to it, it will be
confusing for a while.
All it means is that,
and it works.
So, in fact, you can take all
these terms, you can break
them up this way.
So what you've really done is
you've broken u of t into a
double sub expansion.
These exponentials limited in
time, that entire set of
functions are talking
to each other.
A function living in this
interval of time and a
function living in this interval
of time have to be
orthogonal, because I multiply
this by this and I get
zero at each time.
In one interval these
exponentials are orthogonal to
each other -- we've pointed
that out before.
So we have a doubly exponential,
we have a double
sum of orthogonal functions, and
what we're saying is that
any old L2 function at all
we can break up into
this kind of sum here.
This is a very complicated way
of saying what we think of
physically anyway.
It says take a big long
function, segment it into
intervals of length t, break up
each interval of length t
into a Fourier series.
That's all that's saying.
So it's saying what
is obvious.
We're going to find a number of
such orthogonal expansions
which work for arbitrary
L2 functions.
As I said, it's a conceptual
basis for voice compress
algorithms.
Even more, next time
we're going to go
into the Fourier integral.
You think of the Fourier
integral as being the right
way to go from time to
frequency, but, in fact, it's
not really the right way to
go from time to frequency.
When we think of voice or you
think of the wave form of a
symphony, for example,
what going on there?
Over every little interval
of time you hear various
frequencies, right?
In fact, if you make t equal
to the timing of the music,
the idea becomes very, very
clean because at each time
somebody changes a note.
So you go from one frequency to
another frequency, so it's
a rather clean way of
looking at this.
Our notion of frequency that
we think of intuitively is
much more closely associated
with the idea of frequencies
is changing in time then
it is of frequencies
being constant in time.
When we look at a Fourier
integral, everything
is frozen in time.
As soon as you take the Fourier
integral, you've
glopped everything from time
minus infinity to time plus
infinity all together.
Here when we look at these
expansions, we're looking at
these frequencies changing.
There's an unfortunate part
about frequencies changing,
and that is frequencies,
unfortunately, live over the
entire time interval.
These truncated frequencies
work very nicely but they
don't quite correspond to
non-truncated time intervals,
but it still does match our
intuition and this is a useful
way to think about functions
that change in time.
If you believe what I've just
said, why do people ever worry
about the Fourier
integral at all?
Well, you see the problem is
this quantity t here that I'm
segmenting over is unnatural.
If I look at voice, there's no t
that you can take which is a
natural quantity.
The 20 milliseconds is just
something arbitrary that
somebody did once
and it worked.
Too many other engineers in
the field said, well that
works, I'll pick the same thing
instead of trying to
think through what a better
number would be.
So they all use the same t.
It doesn't correspond to
anything physically.
So, in fact, people do
try the same thing.
Let me just say what a Fourier
transform is and we'll talk
about it most of next time
because that's the next thing
we have to deal with.
Something you're all familiar
with are these Fourier
transform relationships.
There's the function
of time, there's
the function of frequency.
You can go from one to
the other, mapping.
Well, if you know this
you can find this.
If you know this, you
can find this.
It looks a little bit like the
Fourier series, and usually
when people learn about the
Fourier integral they start
with a Fourier series and start
letting t become large,
which doesn't quite work.
But anyway, that's what
we're going to do.
If the function is well-behaved,
the first
integral exists and
the second exists.
What does well-behaved mean?
It means what we
usually mean by
well-behaved, it means it works.
So again, this theorem here is
another example, or not, as
the case may be.
But we'll make this
clearer next time.